c'est un plan de sauvetage colossal une
première réforme d'envergure pour
l'administration maiden qui souhaite
frapper vite et fort pour sortir le pays
de la crise provoquée par la pandémie
un plan d'un montant de 1900 milliards
de dollars soit près de 1600 milliards
d'euros l'équivalent de 9 % du pib
américain l'objectif de cette loi
agir massivement en faveur de la
croissance économique du pays et ainsi
alimenter les liquidités des ménages des
états et des entreprises du pays
d'après la maison blanche cette
législation devrait créer plus de 9
millions de nouveaux emplois cette année
et rendre les soins de santé plus
abordable pour les américains les
républicains y voient des mesures qu'ils
qualifient de gauchistes et dénonce un
endettement colossal avec ce plan de
relance
le texte déjà adopté mardi soir en
première lecture devrait être approuvée
grâce au vote des démocrates qui
contrôlent la chambre des représentants
malgré la fronde des républicains il est
difficile pour nous de comprendre
comment les républicains peuvent voter
contre ce projet de loi car il a un tel
effet pour les électeurs nos élus sont
bien conscients de cela
ainsi que de la valeur de l'excellence
intellectuelle de ce que contient la
législation
donc nous sommes assez confiants à ce
sujet et nous vous remercions de
l'attention que vous partagez projet je
suis tellement enthousiaste je ne peux
tout simplement pas le cacher ce
programme sera le troisième plan de
sauvetage adopté par le congrès
américain depuis le début de la pandémie
le premier avait été promulguée par
donald trump en mars 2020 pour un
montant de 2200 milliards de dollars le
pib américain s'était contracté de 3 5%
l'année dernière la pire année depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale